2010 est une année de catastrophes
naturelles aux états unis inondations
ouragans feux de forêt sécheresse secoue
le pays d'est en ouest 16 événements
météorologiques extrêmes ont tué 362
personnes et coûté plus de 300 milliards
de dollars
la nasa est catégorique la planète se
réchauffe et le rythme alarmant
l'image est clair la terre passe du bleu
ou rouge depuis 1880 se passe en
campagne dans notre chambre annonce déjà
ses couleurs pour l'actuel président
américain la hausse des températures est
un canular
il nomme scott frites à la tête de
l'agencé américaine de protection de
l'environnement menées profite doute
qu'il fallait maintenir sous les 2
degrés celsius l'augmentation des
températures d'ici 2100 une cible qui
rallie la communauté scientifique
la priorité est maintenant à l'emploi
l'administration trump démente l un à un
les règlements de l'ère obama qui
combattait les gaz à effet de serre le
président veut même relancer l'industrie
du charbon une des plus polluantes
le coup de massue aux
environnementalistes viendra en juin
2010 est le président des états unis se
retirent de l'accord de paris qui lutte
contre les changements climatiques
l'administration ne chôme pas perdu à
ornans toute crédibilité à l'étranger
sur les questions de protection de
l'environnement
le deuxième plus important pollueur au
monde et maintenant le seul pays à ne
pas adhérer à l'accord de paris ici
christian latreille radio-canada
washington